حسنًا، يموت طفل واحد على الأقل بسبب
سوء التغذية كل ساعتين في السودان.
مخيم زمزم وفقًا لمنظمة أطباء بلا حدود
الخيرية الطبية مينيس سان فرونتير، يعد زمزم
واحدًا من أكبر وأقدم مخيمات
النازحين في البلاد.
الصراع في السودان مستمر بسبب
القتال العنيف.  اندلعت اشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكرية
في أبريل، إذا كنت تتذكر
العام الماضي، وقد تأثرت منطقة دوال
بشكل خاص بالعنف المتفشي،
وتقول الأمم المتحدة إن أكثر من ستة
ملايين شخص نزحوا
داخل السودان وفر 1.5 مليون آخرين
بسبب الصراع.  يمكنك رؤيتهم تلك الخريطة إلى
البلدان المجاورة والتي تشمل
تشاد، المتحدث باسم اليونيسف جيمس إلدر
ينضم إلي الآن من أدرا في تشاد، فهو يتحمل
مسؤولية التحدث عن
الأزمات الإنسانية في جميع أنحاء العالم.
جيمس من الرائع رؤيتك مرحبًا بك مرة أخرى
في العرض، أعني ذلك
إحصائية مروعة ذكرناها للتو
لمشاهدينا، يموت طفل واحد بسبب
سوء التغذية كل ساعتين، وهو أمر
يصعب فهمه، فقط أخبرنا
بما رأيته على
الأرض، حسنًا، مرحبًا، قل انظر بالضبط، هذا هو
السبب في أن لديك هذه الأعداد المذهلة
من الأطفال الذين يعانون من ذلك  أشد أشكال سوء
التغذية الحاد، النوع الذي سيقتل
طفلاً، لديك
أكبر عدد من الأطفال النازحين في العالم
هنا، الأنظمة الصحية على وشك
الانهيار، لذلك هناك
ساعة تدق حتى نشهد هذه
الخسارة الملحمة في الأرواح و  ولهذا
السبب هناك محاولة واسعة النطاق للحصول على
أكبر قدر ممكن من المساعدات
عبر هذه الحدود. لقد كنت في دار
مرة أخرى اليوم، أعني عيسى، كنت في دار منذ أربع
سنوات مضت وما زلت أستطيع سماع
تلك القصص التي روتها لي النساء.  عن
الاغتصاب، وقصص الأطفال الذين
قُتلوا، تلك الفتيات الصغيرات قبل 20 عامًا
أصبحن أمهات، وهن الآن نفس
الأمهات الذين أتحدث إليهم بهذه
القصص المروعة عما عانوا منه من
حرق المنازل والاغتصاب وما إلى ذلك،
أعني أنني أعتقد أننا  يجب أن نبتعد عن
فكرة أن الفظائع هي
جانب لا مفر منه من الحرب، فهي ليست
بالطبع قرارات فظيعة
يتخذها القادة، لذلك يقال إن ما
رأيته هو أن القرى والمجتمعات بأكملها
أفرغت هذا الشعور الغريب بعدم وجود
أحد هناك  لأنهم تعرضوا
للحرق والنهب من منازلهم
مرة أخرى، نعم، لقد كنا نعرض
ونشاهد بعض الصور منك
ومن بعض الأطفال المحاطين بأطفال،
صور جميلة حقًا على الأرض
ولكنك تعرف هؤلاء النساء و
الأطفال يعتمدون بشكل كبير على جيمس أه على
الدعم الغذائي من أجل الرعاية الصحية الغذائية،
صحيح أه وكذلك المياه النظيفة ولكن
هذا كان نقصًا في المعروض
لأنني أعني أنني أتساءل عن
المخاوف الأمنية والبيروقراطية ما سبب ذلك
وأعتقد أن هذين الأمرين  أعتقد أن
الشيء الوحيد الذي كانت اليونيسف والأمم المتحدة
تضغط من أجله على نطاق واسع هو
التخلص من هذه العوائق البيروقراطية.
أعني فكرة أننا نشهد
فظائع، ونشهد حرمانًا من المياه،
ونشهد شبكات المياه
التي تمتلكها المجتمعات المحلية.  تحمل 100
لوح شمسي تم تدميرها جميعًا ببساطة،
كما قالت لي امرأة، عيسى، إنهم
تعرضوا للنهب وأنهم
لا ينهبون، بل يحرقون الآن،
تحاول المجتمعات إعادة بناء
كل ما في وسعها ولكن هذه هي
اللحظة التي  بحاجة إلى دعم دولي،
دعم دولي من أولئك الذين
لديهم القدرة على وقف هذه الفظائع
والدعم الدولي لمواصلة
توصيل المساعدات، لذلك نحن نحضر 10000
كرتونة إضافية من الأغذية المغذية أي
10000 طفل إضافي ولكننا بحاجة إلى
مضاعفة ذلك ثلاث مرات لنضاعف ذلك أربع مرات، لذا فإن الأمر
بيروقراطي  العوائق الأمنية، لقد
ذهبت إلى دار كل يوم خلال
الأيام القليلة الماضية ويجب أن أخرج في
الليل، وهذا أمر يثير جنون الناس ويضطرون إلى
النوم هناك، علينا العودة،
يجب إصلاح هذا الأمر، نحتاج إلى وقف
الصراع ولكن مرة أخرى  لا يمكننا وقف
الصراع، لذا دعونا على الأقل نتأكد من أن
من يسيطر على المنطقة يحصل على المساعدات للناس،
اسمح لنا بتقديم المساعدات للناس، وسمعت
أحد مسؤولي الشؤون الإنسانية على
الأرض يقول إنك تعلم أنها شعرت بأن
شعب السودان قد تم
التخلي عنه تمامًا.  أن
شعورك نعم أعني انظر هنا نحن عيسى
أنت مرة أخرى مثل رفع الضوء على
الأماكن التي أشعر بها الناس وأنا أعلم أن الناس
يشعرون بذلك وأنا وأعتقد أنهم على
حق وأعتقد أن نظرة العالم قد تحركت
بعيدًا عن هنا و  هناك
سبب عملي وراء هذا الخطأ،
هناك سبب أخلاقي بالطبع لأن
الطفل طفل وهم يعانون
بشدة هنا ولكننا لا نتحدث فقط
عن الخسارة المحتملة للعديد من
الأرواح، لقد قابلت عيسى عشرات الأطفال
في الماضي  الأشخاص الذين تبلغ أعمارهم 20 عامًا والذين تعرفهم والذين
ولدوا للتو في تلك
المذبحة الأخيرة التي وقعت قبل 20 عامًا، درسوا
الهندسة ودرسوا الطب
ودرسوا الاقتصاد، إنهم هذه
القوة النابضة بالحياة اليائسة لتكون جزءًا من
مجتمعاتهم، وكما قال لي أحدهم  أنا
ببساطة لا أستطيع أن أحلم بجيمس، لا أستطيع أن أحلم
هنا، لذا فإن الأمر الوحيد هو أننا
مهددون بهذه الخسارة الكارثية في
الأرواح، ولا يمكننا أن نفقد هذا
الجيل، هذه الفرصة
لجيل حصل على التعليم، ولهذا السبب
يشعرون بأنهم منسيون وإلى حد ما
هم كذلك، وهذا هو السبب  ونحن نحاول مرة أخرى دق أجراس
الإنذار نيابة عنهم